l'actualité en france c'est d'abord la
deuxième semaine du procès en appel de
patrick dils avec un témoignage très
attendu celui de deux pêcheurs qui
affirme avoir vu le tueur en série
francis heaulme le soir du crime
d'après eux son visage était ensanglanté
c'est la première fois qu'une cour
d'assises recueille leurs dépositions
compte rendu d'audience valérie ermite
frédéric bonne emile et joachim ont une
passion la pêche ce dimanche de
septembre à 86 jour du meurtre
ils plient leur matériel et rentrer chez
eux lorsqu'ils découvrent francis
heaulme le long d'une voie ferrée à
quatre kilomètres du lieu du crime au
léman et recroquevillée et son visage
est ensanglanté c'est un mec qui étaient
affolés
c'est un mec je sortais de jeu par il
était bonne en soi il a vu un visage qui
faisait peur un témoignage important
pour la défense mais qui agace les
parties civiles et de pêcheurs auront
attendu quinze ans avant de parler pour
la première fois dans ce procès patrick
dils peut souffler les regards se
tournent désormais vers francis heaulme
le tueur en série heaulme qui témoignera
mercredi nie toujours être l'auteur des
crimes mais il reconnaît aujourd'hui
avoir croisé les enfants en 1992 il
racontait déjà cette scène aux gendarmes
qui l'avaient arrêté en fait le recul
j'aurais plus de cinq ans on a filé sur
france ô
ces affaires
le dire qu'ils évoquent directement la
sphère de montigny lès metz et du
meurtre de ses deux enfants et à chaque
fois qu'il a évoqué une affaire il était
participants cette affaire l'a
d'ailleurs ce jour là et même évoqué
d'autres croient aux petites histoires
qui ont trouvé des épisodes judiciaires
ont été confondus au il n'a jamais de
mobiles poursuit l'enquêteur ces
meurtres sont extrêmement violent et il
a déjà tué à coups de pierres demain
d'autres enquêteurs viendront à la barre
des gendarmes qui ont récemment repris
l'enquêté à zéro
leur conclusion est la suivante le
meurtre des deux enfants de
montigny-lès-metz porte la quasi
signature criminelle de francis heaulme